[Musique]
bureau
à la cérémonie des juno la fête de la
musique canadienne
jérémie dacher porter avec fierté long
cap qui était symbolique pour lui
je crois que l'on peut définir cette
cape comme la terre est la langue et la
langue est la terre ça parle de la
connexion de la relation entre la terre
et la langue sur le devant de la cap
vous avez des fleurs et quand vous
ouvrez la cape c'est écrit en langue tri
nous allons réussir
[Musique]
la langue un élément fondamental dans la
ville de jérémie deutscher ce premier
album
il a tenu à décrire en vol aux stocks la
langue de sa communauté où il a grandi
au nouveau brunswick
la première nation volante aux tic mieux
connu sous le nom de malécites une
langue en voie de disparition
seulement une centaine de personnes là
parlent encore alors ce disque il l'a
fait pour ressusciter cette langue est
il offre d'abord et avant tout à son
peuple à tous les chansons nous avons
chansons traditionnelles qui dit à tous
les membres de ma communauté
c'est pour vous et c'est ce qui m'a
guidé pour cet album je voulais que mon
peuple l'écho qu'il sache qu'il était
pour lui pour moi il y avait un réel
sentiment d'urgence de m'assurer que
j'allais mettre de l'avant cette langue
dans mon travail
il a fallu cinq ans à jérémy pour écrire
et composer cet album alors qu'il était
en train d'étudier la musique à
l'université une aînée de sa communauté
maggie paul lui suggère d'aller au musée
canadienne d'histoire faire des
recherches sur les chants traditionnels
de leurs ancêtres
jérémy passe deux semaines dans le musée
il y retrouve les archives d'un
anthropologue williams h messe ling qui
est au début des années 1900 à des q7
ans au sein d'une communauté de la
première nation volos tokyo les chants
sont enregistrées sur des cylindres de
cire vieux de plus d'un siècle
des pépites d'or pour jérémy
[Musique]
dans son disque le ténor de 28 ans
ressuscite la voix de ses ancêtres et
chante avec eux
[Musique]
dakar 6 nov
and he and sisters cet album est une
conversation entre moi et mes ancêtres
c'est une fusion entre le passé le
présent et le futur
je ramène ses voix du passé pour créer
quelque chose dans le présent et
imaginer un meilleur avenir grâce à
cette musique à bernard fischer un
travail salué par la critique et par le
public
jérémie dacher a remporté le juno du
meilleur album autochtones et le polaris
décerné tous les ans en meilleur album
canadien
toutes catégories confondues un album
que l'artiste va continuer d'offrir aux
canadiens avec notamment une tournée
dans tout le pays à la fin de l'année
accompagné d'un orchestre symphonique
en attendant ce printemps il va
présenter son spectacle en europe et à
new york
l'artiste ne rate aucune occasion de
faire découvrir sa musique sa langue sa
culture son peuple
[Musique]
je suis un peu nerveux à l'idée de
partir et de montrer qui nous sommes
maintenant qu aujourd'hui parce que nous
ne sommes pas figés dans le passé notre
culture nos identités
elle évolue et grandissent et je suis
très excité de montrer au reste du monde
à quoi ressemble maintenant les
premières nations les belles choses que
nous faisons et les belles chansons que
nous chantons
jérémie dacher l'artiste malécites à
l'extravagance assumé qui réconcilie le
passé et le présent qu'il transcende les
générations et qui portent haut le
flambeau de son peuple et des premières
nations
j'espérais tout le monde à comprendre
mes messages et sentir l'émotion de la
musique ici catherine françois radio
canada toronto
magnifique ok